Good morning, Hank, is Tuesday- good morning, John! Oh, we're in a pecan orchard.
It's really nice.
We're on the side of the road in this beautiful pecan orchard.
Hank, it's question Tuesday, the day that we answer real questions from real nerdfighters
First question, Hank, do you have a favorite hat?
Hmm.. Available at dftba.com
only for the next five days along with all the other pizzamas gear!
Extra cool if you wear like this-  oh boy
I mean, that is, that is a dad hat.
Hank, how's the tour been?
Uh, so good, so good, so good.
It's really just two 'so good's.
It's three 'so good's. So good, so good, so good. Hank's right.
Too much or not enough?
I would rather have too much. Oh yeah  - I'm American. John how's the book doing? well
It's been number one on the New York Times bestseller list for three straight weeks
So thank you, everybody.
How does one explain Pizza John to somebody who doesn't know about Pizza John?
I Don't. I feel like it's not something you explain. It's just something you accept
Yeah, you just like it's the guy he wrote The Fault in Our Stars
That's all you gotta say, and then they're like oh, and he's a pizza. Which of you is more of a lightweight?
Clearly me. I mean. he- Hank is the lightest weight. John how sad are you to be missing out on
Saturday at Podcon. I'm sorry to miss the first day of Podcon although there's still gonna
be plenty of live dear Hank and John. I'll still be there, but I'm missing it because I'm interviewing former Vice President Joe Biden
so I'm not that sad because I'm pretty psyched about interviewing former Vice President Joe Biden
I think people know who Joe Biden is you don't have to qualify them every time. Oh, yeah?
I don't? I don't know
Did I ever tell you- poll on the sidebar!
Do you know who Joe Biden is?
I do feel like you could say nothing and Uncle Joe would fill up the time. Good old Uncle Joe.
Oh, god, what if he knows that we call him Uncle Joe? And he introduces himself,
he's like "Hey, John, nice to meet you. I do not appreciate being called Uncle Joe on vlogbrothers".
They're gonna have to like prep him- right- and it's gonna be like so who's this guy was interviewing me
And they're like well actually he made a video about you in a pecan orchard while wearing his own face on his torso.
That was my Joe Biden dance, that was just for Joe. No one else gets to enjoy it.
Hank, are hotdogs sandwiches?
No opinion. WOOAAHHH!
So, a thing that Hank and I have been doing on tour is we have decided that we have too many opinions,
so every day Hank and I are abandoning one opinion.
I've abandoned my opinion on whether a hot dog is a sandwich.
I've abandoned my opinion on Phil Collins's music. I no longer have an opinion about it.
I've abandoned my opinion on other people's opinions of M&M flavors.
Yeah, which is a big deal for Hank because -it was difficult-he was a hardcore anti peanut butter M&M -so bad- nope
But oh you are allowed to love them -there you go
I'm gonna abandon one opinion every day until I find that I am left with some really core important opinions.
Hey, Hank, how would you summarize the book tour experience in the form of a haiku?
You didn't give any prep for this?! you-didn't-give-any-prep-for-this. No. That's- you're not even close.
Nau-se-a-ted bus
Now I'm drunk again.
Han-ging out with John a lot
Birds fly...
...around me...
I don't know if you knew that about the tour experience but every time you go out it's like -woowoo-.
Well, because of the nauseated bus.
Oh right. Cos of the birds flying over- like in the cartoon.
Hey Hank, where can I get Pizzamas gear and for how much longer?
Somebody knows how to get on question Tuesday.
This way
No, you have to go to dftba.com, and it's only available until Friday. Happy Pizzamas everybody!
Hank, I will see you... whenever you get back!
Oh, there you are!
Oh, P.S., Hank, someone asked "Can we get a discount code for Pizzamas merch?"
and I decided, you know what? Yeah!
For the next 24 hours if you use the discount code 'Pizza' you will get...
One percent off- one percent off of your purchase at dftba.com
It's a great discount, Hank. For anything on the whole site? For anything on the whole site. -woah-  One percent.